Cada año, miles de pacientes
pierden la vida a causa del cáncer hepático u oral.
La mejor forma de ayudar a estos pacientes
es realizar un diagnóstico precoz de esas enfermedades.
¿Cómo las detectamos hoy y cómo la inteligencia artificial puede ayudar?
Cuando se sospecha que el paciente tiene alguna de estas enfermedades,
un médico especialista pide tecnologías de escaneo muy caras
como la captación de imágenes por fluorescencia, los TAC o las RM.
Una vez que se obtienen las imágenes,
otro médico especialista hace el diagnóstico y habla con el paciente.
Como pueden ver, es un proceso que requiere de muchos recursos,
médicos especialistas
y costosos equipos de diagnóstico por escáner,
y no se considera práctico para los países en desarrollo.
De hecho, ni siquiera en muchos países desarrollados.
¿Podemos resolver este problema con la inteligencia artificial?
Hoy, si fuera a utilizar arquitecturas de inteligencia artificial tradicionales
para resolver este problema,
necesitaría obtener 10 000...
Repito, cerca de 10 000 de estos costosos aparatos médicos,
y eso para empezar.
Luego, consultaría a un especialista,
que analizaría esas imágenes.
Y con esos dos datos,
puedo entrenar una red neuronal profunda o una red de aprendizaje profundo
para diagnosticar a los pacientes.
Parecido al primer enfoque,
los enfoques tradicionales de IA
tienen el mismo problema.
Gran cantidad de datos, especialistas y equipos profesionales de escaneo.
¿Podemos entonces inventar arquitecturas de inteligencia artificial
más escalables, efectivas y más útiles
para resolver estos problemas a los que hoy nos enfrentamos?
Esto es exactamente lo que hace mi grupo en el MIT Media Labs.
Hemos inventado una variedad de arquitecturas de IA no convencionales
para resolver algunos de los retos más importantes que enfrentamos hoy
en los escáneres y estudios clínicos.
En el ejemplo que compartí hoy teníamos dos objetivos.
El primero era reducir el número de imágenes
necesarias para entrenar a los algoritmos de inteligencia artificial.
Con el segundo fuimos más ambiciosos,
queríamos reducir el uso de estos costosos equipos de tecnología
para escaner los pacientes.
¿Cómo lo hicimos?
Para el primer objetivo,
en vez de comenzar con decenas de miles de estas costosas imágenes,
como la IA tradicional,
comenzamos con una sola imagen médica.
De esta imagen, mi equipo y yo encontramos una manera ingeniosa
de extraer miles de millones de paquetes de información.
Estos paquetes incluían colores, píxeles, geometría
y la representación de la enfermedad en la imagen de diagnóstico.
Es decir, convertimos una imagen en miles de millones de puntos de datos,
reduciendo enormemente la cantidad de datos necesarios para el entrenamiento.
Para el segundo objetivo,
para reducir el uso de los costosos escáneres para examinar pacientes
comenzamos con una fotografía estándar con luz natural
tomada con una cámara DSLR o con el teléfono del paciente.
¿Recuerdan esos miles de millones de paquetes de información?
Superpusimos esos paquetes de la imagen de diagnóstico
sobre esta imagen,
creando lo que llamamos una imagen compuesta.
Para nuestra sorpresa, solo necesitamos 50,
repito, solo 50
de esas imágenes compuestas para entrenar a los algoritmos con gran eficiencia.
Para resumir nuestro enfoque,
en lugar de utilizar 10 000 costosas imágenes de diagnóstico,
hoy podemos entrenar a los algoritmos de IA de un modo poco ortodoxo,
usando solo 50 de estas fotos de alta definición pero estándares,
tomadas con cámaras DSLR y teléfonos,
y establecer un diagnóstico.
Más importante aun,
nuestros algoritmos pueden aceptar, en el futuro o incluso hoy,
algunas fotos muy sencillas y estándares del paciente,
en lugar de los costosos equipos de diagnósticos por escáner.
Creo que estamos preparados para entrar en una nueva era
en la que la inteligencia artificial
incidirá increíblemente en nuestro futuro.
Y, pensando en la IA tradicional,
que es rica en datos pero ineficiente en su utilización,
deberíamos seguir pensando
en arquitecturas de IA no convencionales
que aceptan poca cantidad de datos
y resuelven algunos de los problemas más importantes de hoy en día,
especialmente en el sector de la salud.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)